Florida Republicans have introduced the
bill to ban the Democratic party if this
were to happen if you're a registered
Democrat in Florida you would be
notified your party has been dissolved
canceled for lack of a better term and
you are now an independent slash
unenrolled voter now I'll tell you this
is not going to happen but we shouldn't
ignore this because this is the exact
type of thing that Republicans are
increasingly going to do when you can't
win on policy because you either have
terrible policies or have no policy
ideas you try to win through other means
those means include making it harder to
vote
trying to take an election that you lost
by arguing that it was rigged playing up
these culture War issues and through
other means of subterfuge that's where
the Republican party is right now and
they're going to keep at it